we were the smallest town for a while do
we still wish we were I don't know to be
a population of one in the population of
two and you're both in the same County
in the same state I think that's pretty
wonderful what is the population of mono
i population one me the population of
gross nebraska is one two one two we
don't have enough people it's nothing
against the town's nothing against the
people running the businesses we simply
have run out of people out in this this
area all we have in town is the bank
vault that remains from the Gross State
Bank then we have a community hall and
then our house and a trailer house
across the street
we had a high school here there was
Church until oh maybe the mid 60s
we have the same paperwork and
everything to fill out that Omaha in New
York City and every other city has we
don't have an election for mayor I just
let him keep that job
the young folks or any that go from here
to the city they can adjust pretty well
and make a good life there but you take
somebody that's born and raised in the
city and they usually just can't hack it
out in this area never gets lonely
living in a town - there's always
somebody passing through values are
different you don't have everything at
your fingertips so you just learn to
sitting and converse more I'm not here
because I have to be I can close up and
leave here anytime I want to go wherever
I wanted I'm here because I want to be
here